hi there so I'm dick sites and I've been
doing this sort of thing for 50 odd
years and the thing I like to do is to
understand why things are slow and to
build tools to get the data to explain
why things are slow is it possible for
the people in the room if we can lower
the front lights okay
so I'm going to talk about a problem
that I've dealt with working at places
like Google the solution that I bring to
the table and then give a whole bunch of
examples and then at the end talk about
contributions and take a bunch of
questions so this is the problem I want
to understand why in complex real-time
software this is user facing data center
software real-time controls for
airplanes and cars those sorts of things
why in complex your climb software but
it's sometimes slow sometimes not slow
if you're doing transactions and you
look at some measurement of how long
each transaction takes you find over on
the lower left that there's often a
bunch of fast or normal speed
transactions and then there's some slow
ones in this particular picture there's
one very slow one at the bottom this is
sorted by duration and a bunch of slow
ones and you can see there's an obvious
step function cliffs of these are really
slow these these are medium fastings are
really fast or if you're doing real-time
controls of you know ailerons or
steering wheels or whatever you may have
periodic execution tasks that run like
once every thirtieth of a second or
something and if one task runs too long
then the following task doesn't run on
time and things happen like you drop a
video frame and you're going down the
road at a hundred feet per second or you
know something absurd this is a picture
from a bunch of Google search
transactions showing
just one remote procedure call search
that starts up at the top and then it
does a fan-out in this case of 93
they're not all shown 93 calls to other
machine saying please do a piece of the
search and then get the results back and
rank them and sort them and then display
10 answers what you see over here at
this time diagram that goes 160
milliseconds is some stuff happens the
beginning and then these these parallel
calls go out and they come back at
different times and because you're
waiting for all the answers the last guy
determines the response time and so I'm
the person interested in in these
hindered transactions of wire they start
because my experience has been that if
you can if you understand why why it's
slow there's almost always something you
can do to fix it in about 20 minutes
even if it took you 3 months to figure
out why it's slow it's very gratifying
here's some disk server measurements of
times to go read 64 K or something off
of a disk in a dis server around a
datacenter room and you get the usual
spikes at zero milliseconds of hitting
on on data that's in the in ram cache
you get a spike around 3 milliseconds of
hitting on data that's in the drive in
the drives track buffer then you get the
hump around 15 milliseconds of actually
seeking a reading then you get this long
tail the 99th percentile of this
particular 24-hour measurement 696
milliseconds well the average was back
there or the median actually was back
there at 26 so I'm interested in
understanding the long ones traditional
performance tools as an industry are
incapable of explaining these slow
things counters you know a number of
things that happen performance counters
things like that they only tell you
about average behavior they they don't
distinguish the good cases from the bad
cases they just say here's what happened
overall over the last 10 minutes or
whatever profiles were you sampled a PC
and read them
see what's doing again just average
together the good cases and the bad
cases and and in doing so they drop the
signal-to-noise ratio about the bad
cases by Factor Honor it
they're also blind CPU profiles are
completely blind to not executing an
awful lot of transaction work involves
waiting for something else and if the
picture in your head of what you're
waiting for and the reality of what
you're waiting for it are totally
different you can't explain why it's so
slow because it's waiting on something
you don't you don't understand and
traditional traces where you trace
everything that's happening are much too
slow to use in like live data centers or
in live vehicle control so what we've
done is in industry is we see something
that slow some performance problem you
look at it for a while you study the
circumstances a bit and then you guess
you try some experiment to see if the
guess is right and then you guess again
and my observation is that programmers
are singularly inept at guessing how the
picture of their heads is different from
reality so brought forward a solution
first did this at Google more than ten
years ago but the version I'm displaying
today built from scratch without any any
Google code after I left if you have a
bunch of transactions or events or video
frames or whatever and you don't know
ahead of time which ones are going to be
slow you need to watch everything that's
happening for a while until you get some
bad ones so you can go figure out what
they are like and how they're different
from the good ones and so I'm a strong
believer with this level problem that
all you can do is trace everything
sampling techniques the only sample
because the overhead of your tool is too
high to use all the time so you only use
it a little bit a little bit a little
bit when you're sampling you you
inevitably miss what the real problem is
so Kay you trace is this
but traces all the transitions between
kernel mode and user mode so every
system call system return interrupt
interrupt return fault fault return
every context switch that's all it does
the only reason is fast is it's not
ambitious there are no options there are
no controls there's no sub setting and
the current version the overhead is a
quarter of a percent if you're getting
two hundred thousand events per second
two hundred thousand transitions in user
mode in kernel mode per core so if
you're running a 32 core machine you're
getting 32 times 2,000 events per second
but the total overhead is still a
quarter of a percent so it's like thirty
times faster than trace you cannot use F
trace in a real live data center
environment because it slows everything
down so the point by just tracing the
transitions is time is going on
everything is happening the transitions
tell you right after each transition
what is executing this system cause
executing this interrupt handler is
executing this user program by process
ID is executing there's nothing missing
because I'm just recording the
transitions I'm not recording durations
and so every CPU core give it
transitions into a syst call for
something it's in that doing something
until eventually there's a transition
out in this idea that there's nothing
missing turns out to be really important
because then you can say definitively X
didn't happen for instance if you guess
so this program is slow because it's
waiting on the disk and you take some
you know minute long trace and you look
at it and there are no disk interrupts
you can say it is not waiting on the
disk if you're doing sampling you can't
say that all you can say is when I
looked I didn't see any disk activity
but I didn't look very often
the tracing since it's showing you
everything that's happening on all of
the CPU cores gives you the reason that
everything is slow there's nothing
missing there's no there's no magic from
the outside world that subtly makes a
program executes differently there's
something that that's going on on the
machine in the trace that makes it X to
you differently so why curl user
transitions tracing more events than
that for instance every procedure entry
and exit in user code and in kernel code
it's just too slow like I could not make
I've tried I can't make a tool that does
that with one percent overhead 14
percent yes one percent no Tracey fewer
events like just context what you saw
you're running this program do I need
that programming means it's a third
program that has even lower overhead but
it doesn't give you enough information
to explain why why things are slow so
this is the just right part like I can
assign every nanosecond for every CPU
core what it's doing with very tiny
overhead everything else is post
processing so this is the mechanism this
is implemented in Linux there is over on
the far left some user code there's the
Linux kernel there's a handful of
patches the current patches are in
nineteen files only because the
interrupt handling in x86 Linux is
scattered across half a dozen different
files timer interrupts are different
from the regular interrupts and there's
handfuls of special cases and the
patches are on the order of two lines
per file saying trace the beginning of a
system call trace the end of a system
call that's that that's the set of
patches in this get in the SIS call
entry there's trace interrupt handling
end of tracing interrupt handling those
hooks which are just one line macros
that say if tracing is on do this call a
go to a loadable module and if the
module wasn't loaded a tracing is NaN
and
that's that there's a user mode control
program can turn the tracing on and off
and dump the trace file the trace goes
in to raw reserved buffer in the kernel
anywhere from a megabyte to ten
gigabytes or whatever you want and then
after that's right out and put on disk
the post process and think about it for
a while mm-hmm
so this is the entire patch free syscall
there's the extra line that's the K
trace one macro that says trace the
beginning of a system call turns out
there's a mapping of the system call
number that has to do with backwards
compatibility with 32-bit system calls
and the register that's passed in is the
Lord or the first argument of the system
call which turns out to be really useful
information it's like which file is
getting touched - which file ID and the
thing being passed for the return is the
return value which could be one of
several dozen error codes or it could be
things like the number of bytes read and
having that number turns out to be
really useful in looking carefully at
what's going on then there's this
post-processing chain of a few programs
that takes over all trace file turns it
into individual events just long text
files and then there's an event to span
program that takes all the transitions
and turns them into time spans and so
its output is a bunch of back to back
time spans that cover every CPU core
every nanosecond of the entire trace and
the trace is typically run 30 seconds to
a couple minutes I haven't found the
need to do more than about two minutes
you learn an awful lot in two minutes
but there is a flight recorder a version
where you can just trace continuously
until you stop and then you get to see
the previous 30 seconds to two minutes
then there's finally a little bit that
takes the JSON and turns it into an HTML
file and I'll show you output from a
bunch of those
so I'm going to go through four sets of
examples first one is hello world so
this is hello world I simply added to it
two lines one of which is a call to this
is user code a trick a trace library
that says add a marker to the trace that
says hello and after the printf Adam
working to the trace that says slash
hello I just picked the slash convention
for like HTML tags you compile it on it
and I'll show you a bunch of diagrams
with this notation these are all gonna
be time lines per CPU core and the thin
black lines are the idle tasks the tall
I colored lines are kernel-mode
execution and the half-light ones are
user mode and the middle colors just
distinguish by process ID mod 15 a mod
17 which processes run a nor did sis
call number mod 15 of on 17 you get
different colors or different sis calls
that kind of thing for the kernel stuff
things that are false have pink edges
and things that are interrupt handling
have blue edges and things that are
system calls i've green edges so you can
distinguish and those are the only three
ways of getting from user mode to kernel
mode there's nothing else you get a
two-bit ECC or in memory there's a
machine or interrupt and so you're doing
interrupt handling so this is a trace of
hello world user mode only looking at
the 40 milliseconds here's the flag at
the beginning of the main program here's
the flag it put into the trace at the
end of the main program and it just says
I'm executing this hello world program
the colors or whatever the process ID
was for hello world and there's some
camps as you'll see in this whole thing
is 40 micro seconds so not very
interesting most user mode tools in this
industry that's all you get to see
and that almost never explains why
complex software is slow so here's the
same picture with all the the rest of
the user mode execution the previous
picture was this part over here on the
right and the dotted lines all of this
other stuff is getting hello world
started in fact it actually started over
here on CPU three ran for a little while
got migrated over to CPU one and then
ran for a while and then finally got to
the first line of main this is all
setting up stacks and opening to sis out
and all these things and back here it's
like reading it off disk in this case
reading it from the file cache in memory
because I read this program twice and I
trace the second one okay but here's
what's in the gaps it's all the user all
the kernel mode code and most of which
are page faults it turns out and that's
not a complete picture at all what's
going on because here's all of the other
stuff going on on the same machine at
the same time all the other programs and
if you have interference with your
program from other programs
you only can learn what's going on if
you can see the other programs okay so
this is now for CPU cores and we can see
everything that's going on every one of
them it turns out CPU zero is only doing
the idle job there's a timer interrupts
way off to the right and left but this
is the complete picture what's going on
including it on CPU - this happened to
have a program that's just running
continuously beating memory to death and
possibly and in fact would be slowing
down something on CPU zero there were
something running there and you will see
that in example four so that's just to
calibrate yes
sure so let me let me repeat the
question
what's the overhead of putting these
marks in Oh minus the hello world printf
no no but that's fine I will talk about
the overhead of the tracing and why it's
so small and the including the overhead
of those two calls because the top row
that's all white is CPU zero the middle
row is CPU one that has some stuff on at
CPU two is white and CPU three down at
the bottom is executing oh yeah because
processed 55 was running on CP u 3 and
then later processed 55 was running on
CP u 1 I'm tracing all the context
switches that's part of what happens
inside of the kernel scheduler when
you're when you're leaving an interrupt
or something
of course that's that's where the colors
are coming from if you don't record the
process number you have no idea what's
running just like you don't record the
SIS call number you have no idea which
system calls are running yeah go on
quick two questions than I have to keep
going I'm getting to that
but but not in this example they're
doing things like setting up the stack
they're all copy on writes of stuff
that's allocated and and all the points
table entries point to the all-0 page
and then the first time you write to it
you take a page fault and inside the
page all routine you says oh this is
just starting up a copy it go find a
real page copy all the zeros into it
slowly
nobody optimized the am i copying from
the all zero page just store zero stop
reading the zeros and then go back and
then the page fault doesn't happen
because you've made the PT writable
pointing to the real page and then it
goes on and writes the stack for the
first time so that's a sort of your
quick calibrate
and so I took some traces of the Linux
schedulers there's a completely fair
schedule or CFS which is the default and
it simply runs each task at equal speed
and each task is supposed to get if you
have five CPUs and 50 tasks each tasks
is supposed to get one tenth of the CPU
times the first-in first-out schedulers
intended to be real-time scheduler that
the first program that arrives and runs
to completion and then the next thing
runs and then the next thing first-in
first-out
round-robin says oh that's very good but
if the first thing blocks will go put it
at the end of the queue so that all the
other things can run and then later
these were layered with oh if it's run
for a while wow maybe we should go ahead
and and preempt it and let one of the
other things run and in particular if
you're running a high priority real-time
task that's in a tight loop by a common
mistake you'd like to be able to get
control see and things like that to
actually get some cycles so you can kill
it so this preemption two that were
useful so I simply ran the three
different schedulers with a little
program that spawns one task and then
when that finish responds to and when
those finish wants three up through
twelve and each of those tasks simply
does a bunch of checksumming of a 240
kilobyte array chosen to mostly fill up
the l2 cache and here's what they look
like we have in time I've sorted now by
process ID instead of sorting by CPU
number same data different sort really
useful so by process ID there's bashes
up at the top here and it spawns one
process that it runs for about a second
and it's done and then and the top level
program spawns two processes and that
when they finish it spawns three and
then four and out here as well as twelve
you'll notice it gets longer longer
longer because there's only four CPUs so
after four CPUs the total run time
starts getting longer because they have
to actually swap off I'm gonna look at
the trace of seven of these so here's
what happens with this
completely fair scheduler there's seven
lines here showing seven different
processes and when they're running so
there's a context we are switch here
that starts this process in 12
milliseconds later the context switch
that stops it and starts some other
process first thing I noticed is process
seven stopped back here in process one
stopped way out there there's a 30%
variability in how long it took these
seven processes each of these seven
processes to run this is not completely
fair you also notice that there's
unpredictably these stretches where some
processes run for a lot more than 12
milliseconds and they don't get switched
out the first-in-first-out scheduler
starts this guy and it doesn't run very
much
that's the first one launched the second
one launched runs so the first 3
launched actually take a long time the
fourth one it's a shorter time and
there's an 18% variance there and the
round-robin one looks pretty similar to
the first-in first-out since it's only a
small modification and there's a 22%
variance so I'd like to explain be able
to explain these long ones why aren't
they all fast so we get to look at a
little more what's going on this is now
in detail the last picture was 2.2
seconds across the page across the
screen this is 120 milliseconds of just
the beginning of launching seven and
then one of the launch threads runs
another one runs and after 12
milliseconds context switches context
switches back context switches context
switches back and across this if you
look a little further out there's all
seven of them slopping around
periodically over here on the right
there's starting everything up and you
may notice these dotted lines of
connecting making something runnable
with where it actually runs and how much
later it actually runs so I'm going to
zoom in on the startup the startup has
two views the top four lines are the
CPUs
the bottom seven eight lines are the
individual processes again the same data
so this this lump of execution on CPU
zero is exactly that love of execution
for the batch process this lump over
here is exactly there's two lumps there
is that one in that one so what we see
at the beginning is with these four
arrows is bash does four clone calls to
start up the other threads but the other
three clone calls happen later not in
the picture in your head
the reason they happen later is these
three threads that are started actually
start and bash gets context switched out
because they're all running equal
priority and if finally gets back in
here and gets another thread going and
then it gets contest switched out and
finally gets back in here and gets
another car going it so this last guy
starts 400 what microseconds later than
the first one this is just an example of
the kind of dynamics that sometimes
there there are hundreds of thousands of
microseconds and dozens of milliseconds
there's several more things going on
here
so these threads that are cloned they
don't actually start immediately but
they start fairly soon and the first
thing they do is they stop executing and
they don't do real execution to kill out
here ways so I'm going to zoom in a bit
more I have to explain the notation
first these dotted lines for the process
lines are showing what it's waiting for
when it's not running
so we trace that this little piece of
code runs and then it blocks technically
it goes into the kernel scheduler it
goes out of the kernel scheduler it goes
into idle after awhile it comes out of
idle by there's an interrupt that
happens or the schedule or distribute to
a cross process that are out from an
interrupt routine on a different core or
whatever and the scheduler says oh I can
run this guy again and in between
depending on what is going on there may
be some other process that sets the
runnable bit for the one that's going to
start up
saying you can now run and so I simply
look at which piece of the kernel is
executing when the set runnable bid is
done if it's executing inside of the
disk interrupt handler then I say I was
waiting on disk if it's executing inside
the network receiver transmit interrupt
handler when it says make that other
thread runnable and say all that thread
was waiting on the network if a threat
is made runnable but doesn't run because
it doesn't have a CPU assigned to it
because for instance the CPUs are all
busy doing other stuff then it's waiting
for a CPU and I mark that in the
post-processing it's all done in the
post-processing it's not done by adding
extra trace entries those entries are
already there other than the micron 0.3
which turned out to be a key thing why
do you for memory is the page fault yeah
so what's going on here I think I have
this on the next slide yeah
so this is an expansion of that so
what's happening up here is CPU 0 up
here on the left
clones these other threads with lazy
sharing of the pages remember these are
child processes sharing memory with the
parent process so the first thing that
happen is one of these child processes
it starts executing and bam if it's a
page fault on this first copy-on-write
except that because of the lazy the bash
hasn't actually finished setting up the
sharing but it has it has a lock so this
first page fault has to wait for Bash to
run and get its M protect system call
together and actually get things going
and in the middle of M protect that
wakes up the guy that the back here was
waiting to say okay you can go finish
your page fault now and this bouncing
back and forth happens until everybody
has their memory Pte set up properly to
share and and then and then you're off
and running so there's a lot of bouncing
back and forth to get started but you
you expect that doesn't matter very much
but you would be wrong because you might
find in some programs that you're in
this kind of behavior all the time but
you don't know it and of course you
notice there's a lot of idle time and
there's a sign waves that we'll get to
what things aren't executing very much
so in fact there's 382 microseconds of
idle time this 320 is is the elapsed
time so there's four times that total
time to be accounted for 540
microseconds are the sine waves that
we'll get to if we could get rid of
those two this whole thing this whole
stir up would be three times faster so
we'll get back to that a bit you have to
talk about power saving on modern
processors running on batteries yes what
would happen if you if you didn't do
lazy copy-on-write to do pages as
somebody says so malloc a megabyte you
simply allocate a megabyte of real
memory space and you fill all megabyte
with zero what happens is everything
gets really slow because there's lots of
stuff that allocates much more space
than it ever intends to use and you
would actually allocate as real memory
and you would you would spend dozens and
dozens of microseconds zeroing it and
nobody's ever going to touch it
FreeBSD did that for awhile and took it
out yeah
okay so so my goal here is not to
explain how to fix all these things my
goal is to show them to you so you can
think about them and you will all have
good ideas and they will all take 20
minutes to fix right but I need to show
you some more examples so first off
drill down a little bit is lottery CPUs
to save power go into deep sleep states
and which time they lower the clock rate
and the voltage in Stairsteps and
coordinated because if you lower the
voltage really quickly and you leave the
clock rate too high that everything
craps out so you have to lower the clock
rate first and then the voltage and then
cooperate involved okay meanwhile after
a while if you're being serious about
saving power you turn off a complete
core to do that you have to turn off its
caches okay to do that you have to write
back everything that's in the cache out
here and you have to reload it back here
because in between it's off it's not
it's not paying attention to who's
else's writing and everything else okay
and and so when it comes back up not
only does it have no concept of who else
has data where it doesn't even have good
parody in any of the cache lines or
perhaps in half of them because you
randomly power up and say off so the
first thing that happens in here is
writing good parity cache lines which
were a 256 K second level cache takes a
little while
several microseconds so this is the
going off this is how it's triggered
this is Intel x86 Intel and AMD 64-bit
there's an EM Wade instruction that
gives a hint to the processor it says oh
you could go into c6 deep sleep now in
this trace this M wait was issued 800
odd nanoseconds
after entering idle the auto loop
actually loops for a little while and it
says oh it's time to do an M wait and
shuts down the CPU core 870 nanoseconds
at the other end there's eventually some
interrupt that gets directed to that CPU
and the hardware says I can't execute
instructions the I cache is off the
secondary cache is off the the clocks
are way low
so so get the ball rolling again and
that takes a while 30 microseconds this
matters if you care about interrupt
latency and some like remote DMA kind of
a network thing and you're expecting
microsecond turnaround and you are
running on a machine that's otherwise on
a CPU core that's otherwise idle BAM
you're doing 30 microseconds all the
time so that's what's going on in this
little game here these are all this guy
runs for a little bit goes into idle
turns off the core the next thing that
happens is somebody else says oh you can
run after all and it takes a long time
to come back up and then it runs for a
little bit and then turns off the core
so in fact in this particular trace if
the M weights weren't there and you just
bounce back and forth this whole thing
would be three times faster you'd never
go into c6 you've wondered spent a long
time so this is the design flaw if it
takes time T to come out of some weird
state you should wait time T before you
go in hoping that you don't have to go
in if you do that you're no worse than a
factor of two off from the optimal
algorithm if you knew what the future
held so going in in less than a
microsecond to something that's going to
cost you 30 microseconds to come out is
just a bad design flaw but one that you
cannot see and no one has seen until
this stuff started happening I have as
it turns out at every time we take I
also record the PC value of the thing
that was interrupted see so I just added
this last week so you can get standard
PC sample profiles of what's going on
inside of user code that's not doing any
transitions to kernel code it's just CPU
bound and I just wanted to show you on
the scale this this is that startup
stuff we were looking at expanded here's
a four millisecond Sampo is a formula
second samplers and other ones so
there's 20 of them on this screen across
the four CPUs
the K you trace has 2,100 samples over
that section of the trace so a hundred
times more information yes no turning
off too soon is a bad idea attorney if
you're going to be off for four
milliseconds by all means turn off it's
a good decision to turn off if you have
a cell phone because you care about the
battery and you don't care about the
performance it's a bad decision to turn
off if you don't need to turn off
because you're about to do something
just a few microseconds later and that
happens a lot in data centers and until
we could see it until I added the sine
waves we didn't know what was happening
so here's a example three this is a
client and a server so machinae a sends
some requests to machine B machine B is
running this toy in memory database it's
it's a C++ map key and value and machine
a a hundred times says go right this
megabyte into the database sometimes
later there's going to be a million
reads or something but right now it's
just the right both the client and the
server in this setup report about
eighty-five transactions per second or
about 11.5 milliseconds per transaction
the server over here B reports that each
transaction actually only takes one and
1/2 milliseconds of user time user
compute on and only about 2.8
milliseconds of elapsed time and the
server reports that is 97% idle you
might want to get more than 85
transactions per second if you could
understand why it's so slow so here's a
little trace this is a a few seconds of
Cronos is less
a few seconds and I'm like this is the
second across and we have these little
flags because I put that into the toy
program so we could see what was
happening but but all of the annotation
stuff is optional so this says right
right right so these are the beginnings
of the bunch of rights and some of them
it's running on CPU one some of them
returning on three CPU three some of
those learning on CPU zero because this
thing is getting migrated around as it's
blocked and as others stuff could be
running in this case nothing else is
running but the operating system is
migrating stuff anyway which might not
have been in the picture in your head
okay so if we look at the beginning this
is actually the right I screwed up and
over wrote it with what this thing is
which is a read and this thing over here
is a bottom half interrupt handler for
our X for receiving from the from the
network so what's happening here is
we're getting Network interrupts
networking and written networking
they're up and the client that I'm sorry
the server program is doing read read
read read of the the data just came in
and this read for instance returned a
length of 0 but the reads back here were
returning lengths that were on the order
of 1,800 bytes
this is the megabyte coming across the
network ah now you do the arithmetic and
megabyte per second it's a gigabit per
second Network link in line that desk at
home so it's around 100 megabytes per
second so a megabyte should take about
10 milliseconds to go across the wire
and you can interview you've zoomed
around on this you could see all 10
milliseconds I'll be going across the
wire in pieces you're not going to get
more than 85 transactions per second
because you're waiting on the network
it's all busy ok however there's more
there's all these page faults after we
finally get up and going we get a
megabyte it's sitting in a kernel mode
buffer actually the city and kernel mode
buffers and chunks of about 18,000 bytes
this particular protocol for remote
procedure calls the receiving and we
reads a header for a message that could
be our
surely long and the header says how long
the rest is at which time this program
Malick's in this case a megabyte
actually 1 0 0 0 0 bytes and then as the
data comes in
it ends up copying that into the
allocated space which is actually going
to be a string in the map that's getting
that is the database so there are 245
page faults in a row here and that is 1
0 0 0 0 0 divided by 4096 rounded up
it's the right number of page faults for
the length that sent it's also all
wasted effort and that's why this is so
slow at the beginning but it's the same
game as the copy-on-write zeros for
allocated stuff and there's some some
timer interrupts in the middle you'll
notice these two timer interrupts start
sooner than that timer interrupts
in fact they start sooner by pretty much
the length of the sine wave which is 30
millisecond microseconds it turns out on
this particular processor CPU cores 0 &
2 are too hyper threads there's only one
physical processor core and 1 in 3 3
isn't shown are another hyper threaded
on the other of the two cores and what
you see here is the time render it comes
in on a CPU core that's busy no delay
this one comes in on a CPU core that
mile to the left my left went into deep
sleep with an M wait and this is coming
back out at E sleep so you can see from
the transition measurements you can
absolutely confirm what the timing is
for coming out of sleep it turns out the
intel numbers has documented or off by a
factor of 10 they said that the counts
involved in this table in the Linux
kernel were microseconds they're tenths
of microseconds and I just proved it
with this picture ah so we've got
sending a megabyte nothing to do about
changing that other than the binary
faster network but if you want more than
85 that's the thing you do because you
know you know you know
that's the bottleneck okay the client
takes about 1 and 1/2 milliseconds after
finishing a right I didn't show this
here but but when the server sends back
is you know 10 bytes says I'm done
the next incoming Network packet
interrupt is about 1.5 milliseconds
later that means it took the client that
long to get its act together to do the
next request so 1.5 milliseconds to do
the next request so you can conceivably
could go figure out why the clients so
slow and speed that up or a double
buffer you know the usual things you can
all solve this problem now that you know
what it is yes can you correlate these
across machines absolutely all of the
stuff is mapped back in to get time of
day and if you have two machines and you
get time of day on the two machines you
come pretty close and I can explain how
close but if you then adjust the times
to be within about a microsecond of each
other you can line up what the client
did and what the server did in time
perfectly and you do that not by having
fancy expensive hardware you do that by
saying oh I sent this thing and it
arrived over here and I sent this answer
back in it right over there and you get
bounds on how far on what the offset
could possibly be between the two clocks
on the two machines and pretty soon you
get some packets that aren't impeded in
any way and just so let's open get there
and and you do short things like pinging
or whatever now and then or ACK and you
get some really tight bounds and then
you do that early init race and do that
late inner trace and you also then can
calculate the slope of how the two
clocks are drifting with respect to each
other over the course of a minute or so
and then you line them up every every
year when I thought about this I have my
students write that program because then
they know they don't need to buy
expensive hardware so and the final
thing of course is all these page faults
and that's because of this malloc and
free malloc and free Malka free and if
you just had
if the server allocated static buffers
perhaps reallocating until they're big
enough and then just reuse
you get rid of all that and that's the
one performance thing that's worth doing
here so there's more some of the
transactions are three times faster than
the others here's one transaction that
takes fourteen hundred microseconds the
very next one it's a very next one took
four hundred eight microseconds and
there's a bunch of the slow ones and
then there's some phase change and then
there's a bunch of fast once and then
there's a phase change and there's a
bunch of slow ones so we're back to why
so one of the things it can do when I'm
reading the time at every transition I
can also read the number of instructions
retired and so you have a transition
here of a transition here you read the
number you read the cycle counter here
you mean cycle counter there you
subtract you read the instructions
you're tired here you read the
instructions that retire there you
subtract you divide you get instructions
per cycle not over the course of ten
seconds over the course of three
microseconds or whatever this interval
is that you're measuring so these little
triangles are displaying like a
speedometer they're displaying the
instructions for cycle over here on
pointing to the far left flat is zero
instructions per cycle and over here we
don't have it in this picture of the
triangle were pointing flat to the
writer before instructions to recycle
this is an Intel i3 four-issue machine
straight up is one dialing up north east
is two instructions per cycle diagonally
up north west is half of instruction per
cycle so what we see here on the slow
thing is the instructions for cycle is
running about 1/4 of an instruction per
cycle one instruction every four cycles
sometimes one instruction every two
cycles down here at the bottom what we
see is it's running 7/8 of instruction
two one instruction per cycle okay so
the reason it's slow is it's taking
longer for every instruction it's not
way do something else it's not how can
that happen
yeah so maybe this guy is running with
lots of cash interference or cache
misses and this guy is running with lots
of cache hits we look in the original
trace they actually might not be
anything else running on the other CPUs
to serving the caches so I don't
actually have a good explanation for
this but the two choices are there's
something good about the cache layout in
the fast case and those these things are
filling up a good chunk of the of the l3
cache on this little processor so maybe
the operating system got to allocating
the same physical pages every time after
you know the hell with this malloc free
malloc free the operating systems it's
all your it's always doing the same 245
pages I'll just give you the same pages
every time they haven't already in the
cache by fluke I don't think that's part
of the design of allocating physical
memory but it would help it helps by
factor of three in this particular case
so these are all things that when you
see them occurring in the code you care
about you know what to do about them
when you can't see them occurring you an
idea quick question
yeah when you allocate memories define
to be zeroed not necessarily when you
allocate it but by the time you use it
in particular by the time you write to
it that's the whole point of this
delayed until you you've got a page
fault and then you do the copy-on-write
that's what all these page faults are
doing yeah so the right answer this was
several slides back is you a better
server design would allocate a buffer
and reuse it the cost of malloc and free
isn't in the time you measured in the
library routine for malloc and in the
library routine for free in the user
code which is the measurement you always
get if you profile and you say I'm
spending 5% of my time in malloc and
free that's wrong the time is right
after that when you do all these copy on
writes that you can't see that's where
the time is really going that's half of
the time in this stretch in this stretch
until it's all up and running we have
crappy tools in this industry to see
what's really going on and it does
matter so example for you sir for three
programs running each of which is
beating to death something like a 100
megabyte array so it's sweeping through
the l3 cache it's always going out to
main memory what we see I picked three
on purpose so two of them have to be
running on the same physical CPU core in
this case one and three but we see these
are running as about five-eighths of an
instruction per cycle and this other one
also simultaneously at about 5/8 of an
instruction per cycle so between them
they're getting a total of 1 and 1/4
instructions out of that physical core
over here on CPU 2 this is running with
only 3 idle jobs contending against it
and it runs all by itself at one
instruction per cycle instead of
five-eighths
so it doesn't quite hit the 2
that these to get and in fact what these
two are doing of course is is each of
them is getting some more instructions
done while the other one is waiting for
the cache miss that's the whole point of
hyper-threading so you get a little bit
more than one CPUs worth of work out of
two of these each getting not half of a
CPU but but somewhere between half and
all of us CPU depending on how many
stall cycles there there are so that's
the advantage you get you get some and
then this thing runs all by itself it
runs fast when it's running
overlapped it runs slower all by itself
it's actually running at one and a
quarter instructions per cycle and in
the overlap case it's running at one
instruction per cycle and here we have a
partial overlap and it's running at one
and then it speeds up when the other two
stop you can learn almost everything you
ever wanted to learn about interference
and hardware sharing just from looking
at instructions per cycle you don't need
the other 39 different performance
counters but you need to look at a very
fine timescale if you're going to
correlate it with what the programs are
doing and therefore what you need to fix
so here's one more example this is a
from the schedule fest this is again the
programs that simply scan through the LV
l2 cache they don't go all the way out
to main memory and over here this guy is
running all by itself on CPU - and this
one all by itself on CPU three this
linear scheduler is hyper threaded where
and puts these on different CPUs on
purpose different physical CPUs when
there's only two things running rather
than putting both on the same physical
CPU and having it having it work hard
and the other ones doing nothing so
these are getting like 1.75 instructions
per cycle standalone and then these two
here on on one and three are the same
core and they're only getting two
instructions per cycle I got it the
other way these are - these are 175s and
175s add up to 3.5 so between these two
on
on one and three I mean simultaneously
on a single-core they are nearly
completely burying the ten cycles or so
for the l1 cache miss that hits nailed
to this is in fact very sophisticated
hardware in this village cheap $79 part
okay so that's what you get to see from
instructions per cycle and you get to
see about all sorts of interference
between programs main memory Bush caches
translation buffers using the non
pipeline floating point divider heavily
in two different programs and they they
they conflict with each other for thirty
five cycles translation buffer missus
microcode walks through the translation
buffer you get all of the interferes
that that's there you get to see in
instructions per cycle dropping and you
get to see what's running on the other
CPU so you get to see why it's dropping
you can't do better than that so here's
a couple quick experimental examples
then I'll finish up and take questions a
friend of mine drew Netflix took a
couple days from the source code that I
put in github and ported it to FreeBSD
instead of Linux and ran it on one of
the 32 core servers that Netflix I guess
they get it from Amazon and did a trace
and we were both amazed I actually spent
some time consulting at a car company
and put this on a six core ARM processor
and we got to see some anomalies I don't
have any of the original data but I have
the picture this is two programs that
are running on two different processors
when a third thing starts up and the
first two that we're out here now or
swapping back and forth on CPU to every
three and a half microseconds all
they're doing is swapping back and forth
they're not making any progress they're
making progress until they go back to
this
no it's an older version of Linux and
they had no idea this dynamic was
happening of course it's of course the
the the problem is is this forded
microsecond system call which they then
had to go deal with but what my job was
to do the traces create traces so we
could all look at them and this is the
beginning of that just expanded you know
three and a half point go seconds Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam but this is just you
know simple loop and every time you go
around the loop to a schedule around the
loop into a scheduled and nobody thought
to say gee maybe I should around the
loop ten times and then do a scheduled
and then then the switching would be
instead of every three and a half
microseconds every 35 microseconds I
have no idea what else is going on there
I do know that this column here is timer
interrupts and and further out in the
trace but I just picked a chunk further
out there's timer interrupts every
microsecond derson every millisecond
yeah but it's serving video traffic
there's a lot live machine and my friend
that Tesla was driving when we took this
trace this is this is the whole point of
it's fast enough that it doesn't distort
and you can use it for real instead of
oh I can use it on my desktop running
Val grind for five days no this is just
it's so fast it's okay
so those are the contributions coming up
first
only tracing for several minutes of
everything that's going on on all of the
cores of machine can help you catch
unpredictably slow things if you know
all of that transaction coming up is
going to be slow then you could do
something simpler but you don't know you
just never know once you understand the
mechanism that makes it slow you can
predict when it's going to happen again
because now you understand it all
mysteries are simple
once you know what they're doing so so
Tracy only works in C chew for real-time
traffic if it overhead is extremely
small 40 CPU cycles 12 and a half
nanoseconds per event including the
average cost of a cache miss out to main
memory every 64 bytes worth of trace
buffer measured by having some program
that does a million system calls and you
run it with an uninstrumented kernel you
run it with an instrument in kernel with
tracing turned off you run it with an
instrument in kernel the trace and
turned on you run it with an instrument
you colonel with tracing turn on and
instructions per cycle turned on and you
count the times and you subtract and you
say ah this is the overhead the overhead
of having the hooks compiled in but
tracing turned off is negligible could
never measure it zero the overhead of
the vanilla tracing is 12 and 1/2
nanoseconds per event that my budget was
50 nanoseconds 50 nanoseconds for an
event every 5 microseconds is 1% version
we built at Google was 50 now seconds of
version I built later for myself is four
times faster when you turn on the
instructions per cycle the overhead is
three-quarters of a percent because it's
like 36 cycles to read the instructions
per cycle counter because it's a micro
code they have all these various choices
you can do and then there's a 20 cycle
divide I did the divide on the fly in
order to keep the size of the trace
small otherwise I'd have to keep both
quotient and both numerator denominator
if I did the device later still it's
less than a microsecond so there's three
things that you can do you can do
execution all everything's going on you
can do waiting of keeping track when
something gets unblocked that's the key
moment you go look at what unblocked it
that's what it was waiting for always so
if the disk interrupt handler unblocked
it it was waiting for disk if it
unblocked inside a few tax it was
waiting for a lock
that's what futex does and with a little
extra work in the locking libraries in
user code if you have a company that
uses common locking libraries across the
whole company you put in the extra ke
trace call that says here's which lock
it is and once you have that then you
have this thing and you can turn it into
not only so 84 lock is waiting for this
lock and the thing that freed the lock
is in the trace that's that's the one
the other thread that did the make
runnable in its locking library when it
said I'm done with this lock oh there's
somebody waiting on it wake them up and
of course it's the fret this the thread
that's holding the lock that you want to
fix for performance it's not the thread
that's waiting if you say oh this thread
is waiting forever for launch you don't
fix that thread you fixed the one that's
holding the lock way too long and that's
something you don't get from the normal
tools okay finally there's this case of
executing but executing slowly
that's the interference case somebody
else is sharing the disks or the
networks or the memory bus or the caches
or whatever or the floating point
divider you get to see those purely from
instructions per cycle so the overhead
I've told you there's this philosophy
that I feel strongly about is there's
nothing missing I give you a trace I
show you every nanosecond not in every
CPU core it's not like I once designed a
disservice goal and I used some
accounting data that the company had
about da how much time that this server
program took and I undersized the
hardware I built by 25% because I was
unaware that the accounting data it is
accounted for kernel execution on behalf
of programs so it wasn't that bad but it
so if you go to if there was a system
call and get a counter for the program
that did the system call over there was
an outbound Network transmit the
transmitter up would get accounted for
with the program but incoming Network
interrupts I didn't know which program
they were for - after was process
you said oh here's an interrupt and
somewhere in the TCP stack much later
you figure out oh it's for that thread
they simply threw away all of the
incoming interrupts from network
processing time and it turned out for a
disc server program that's heavily
loaded on a small machine that was 25%
of all of the CPU time was spent in
interrupt handling for incoming packets
that's why I undersized dit if they had
simply said we don't know where this
belongs to here's the other bucket and
they put in the other bucket you could
see oh other assembly is 25% we better
pay attention the assumption of course
was other was negligible we don't care
the way you figure that out is you have
another bucket you put the stuff in and
you look to you big it is if it's
negligible great you were right it was
25% well you've got some more work to do
so this is built one implementation for
Linux I've moved it to across a couple
versions of Linux takes about half an
hour to put the patches from one version
into another version so we looked at
hello world we looked at the scheduler
dynamics we looked at transactions we
looked across program interference all
of that you can see from this one simple
mechanism of all the transitions nothing
else so the thing this is different
about this is the only tool at least the
only one I know of that it's fast enough
you can run in 6u with live traffic both
in the network traffic sense and in they
wrote an airplane traffic sense keeping
track of the make runnable event turned
out to be a key to understanding the
interactions between threads adding the
instructions per cycle turned out to be
a key to understanding interference and
came from somebody asking me to talk
like this three years ago so how come
you can't tell us about cache
interference and I went off and thought
about it said well if I do instructions
recycle I can so I did that and the so
idea is that if you do a total trace of
some things you got the client-side the
network the server-side executing and
waiting and executing slowly then you
can see exactly why something is slow
you can just read it off the timeline no
guesses and then there's little user
mode libraries you can put in put in
labels and I added the PC tracing last
Friday found a latent bug yesterday and
then there's this post-processing that
produces all the stuff that you can pan
and zoom and you can take two minute
trace and zoom into 10 nanosecond
intervals across the screen so if
anybody is interesting this wanted to
help out a bit these are the kinds of
things that I hope actually not to do
but hope to get someone else to do of
other operating systems and there's a
few things to complete right I would
like to do an arm port to a Raspberry Pi
for I have the Raspberry Pi for that's
as far as I've gotten so far so any
other remaining questions and then we'll
be out of here yeah
no it's used to be two lines of code
somebody in the kernel group complained
to me that that wasn't the right style
for the kernel so I turned it into a
macro the macro expansion is if K you
trace is on then call this routine in
the loadable module that's the entire
expansion it just puts it just puts
another four byte entry into the trace
so the trace entries are four bytes
that's why it's fast there's 12 bits of
what event happened that covers 300 odd
system call off screen around system
returns 300 odd 32 bit backwards
compatibility system calls that are
different 32 bit 32 that returns a
couple hundred interrupts a couple
hundred faults context switch if you
other things like I'm a label that's it
12 bits of event number and 20 bits of
timestamp timestamp is the cycle counter
shifted over 6 bits so it increments
about every 18 to 20 nanoseconds and it
wraps around every 18 to 20 milliseconds
20 bits million okay and so I end on
getting timer interrupts at least once
per wrap around so that there's an event
so that everything of creating the high
order cycle counter bits is done in
post-processing
know the the call that I had on the
screen passes in the event number it
says I'm doing a system call and I Ord
in the system call number yeah I'll do
four and then we'll stop
I'm more to be more useful but it makes
the trace bigger I mean if you want more
you can use F trace 30 times slower you
can record all of the parameters and you
can you can have run kind decoding in
which system call has five parameters
and which has two I wanted something I
could run in a real data center during
the busiest hour of the day with no
slowdown the so the what's stored in the
trace is just the Lord or sixteen bits
of the first parameter but that's really
useful it's good enough it's an
engineering balance when I entered the
instructions for segue I had to add four
bits to every entry which I did with a
parallel array of bytes because I didn't
want to you know make all the entries
twice as big question if I could only
have four CPU performance counters yeah
issue slots so of a machine can issue
four instructions per cycle four times
the number of cycles and I mean the real
cycles not the constant cycles depending
on if the if the clock is slower then
there's fewer sets of four issue slots
per second if the clock is faster
there's more issue thoughts so number of
issue slots just a freerunning counter
keeps getting larger number of issue
slots with instructions in them the ones
that don't have instructions in them are
waiting on the I cache they may be no
they I catch because it's a cache miss
they may be waiting on the I cash
because there was a branch mispredict
and it's going back to the front of the
pipeline to go fetch or whatever and
it's six cycles away before you get to
the issue slot but whatever so issue
slots that have instructions in them
issue slots that have instructions in
them that actually issue if they don't
issue means you're waiting on the back
end typically you're waiting on a back
end loader store unit that's that's got
24 of them in front of you but you could
be waiting on the not pipeline a
floating-point divide unit but almost
everything else in backends these days
are fully pipeline you can start a new
one of whatever every cycle so those
don't wait until you get backed up in
some way ok and then the fourth one is
instructions retired
okay with those four you could subtract
instructions retired from issue slots
that actually issued and the difference
is speculative instructions that were
thrown away and sometimes that's a big
number and so you need to know you can't
assume all that's trivial forget it you
might find you're spending thirty
percent of your program in that and you
need to restructure your branching stuff
a bit or you need to switch your
algorithm a little bit so you're doing
table lookups instead of if-if-if okay
once you see speculative execution
popping up as it's noticeable you almost
always could fix it in twenty minutes
okay so those are the four counters it's
really helpful to have a fifth thing
which is a free running one hundred
megahertz counter just every ten
nanoseconds does not change based on the
clock going faster or slower battery
saving whatever and it's the same for
all the cores and nobody can write to it
it just keeps counting and and that to
be read in one cycle not thirty six
cycles and to be read without having to
set up these other control registers to
say the thing I want to look at is what
time it is you know and by the way when
I do that nobody else can do looking at
some other counter there's global state
the way these things are now which is
terrible I mean when I run gathering
IPC's I take over the the performance
counters for the whole machine for
whatever the multiplexer is that has
instructions none of the other choices
that aren't just overwrite them in the
kernel with okay here's what I'm going
to measure and to hell with everybody
else which is not a good design okay the
other thing is to have the performance
counters the four that I named be per
process per thread so that they are
saved and restored at context which time
along with the other registers I think
of them if you've got sixteen registers
as four more registers save all twenty
new thread restore all twenty
and they should be one cycle read the
time stamp counter is free running when
you get a chip that has constant times
tab counter but nobody tells you what
its frequency is you have to go screw
around in an operating specific system
specific way to find out oh this is 3.6
gigahertz on this other machine right
next to it is 3.2 key guards okay and
and you and you have to keep writing
that code you know every time for every
new version of every operation but
sometimes you have to go read /proc /dp
info in ascii and pull out some
characters crazy if it were architected
as just a hundred megahertz and
everybody has a hundred megahertz
counter that's the thing they're
multiplying up to get 2.7 gigahertz 2.8
2.9 it's a hundred megahertz counter
with a multiplier in a face lock loop I
just want to count the hundred megahertz
no you can't measure it reliably because
because it's constant but you might be
running on a machine that's coming out
of idle and and it's not actually
running anywhere near that speed while
you're measuring and then you're off by
a factor of two or you get interrupts in
the middle and you could screw around
and you can build routines that's sort
of more or less measure but that's crazy
just architected a constant rate thing
that everybody knows that the
documentary rate I've got two more
questions to do awesome yeah
yeah so if you're concerned about
battery time or temperature variations
in clock speed and stuff you could you
can use current tools to measure a lot
of those things because they're they're
millisecond scales I mean when something
gets hot it doesn't get hot in a
microsecond it gets hot in tens of
milliseconds so there's no point having
a carefully engineered fast transition
thing measuring you just need to have
some user mode program that reads if you
wanted to really care about battery
consumption you would want to get the
apples and Samsung's of the world to
deliver better measurements by process
ID of who the hell's using up the
battery but it only needs to be by
process ID it doesn't need to be by
microsecond by microsecond so last
question you have to program the PMU
counter in order to get instruction if
you're tired there is no things like
that it's exactly that number it's a
pain in the ass and it's different on
the a on the rise ins that on the i3 so
you have to do you have to have the
loadable module that does this has to
have code in and says you know what
process there am I on it's crazy
okay I'm on Don thank you very much
[Applause]